>>Jeff Chang: All right.
Can everybody hear me?
Cool.
Well, good morning and welcome to the third
day of Google I/O. Thank you everybody for
coming to this.
And I'm excited to see so many bright faces
here.
And this is the Chrome fireside chat.
We try to do this every year as an opportunity
for you guys, the developer community, to
engage with us, the Chrome team.
So today we have a few product managers and
a few engineering managers here today to take
your questions.
If you look over on that screen, there is
a URL there that you can go to which will
bring you to that page that you see on the
left over there where you can submit questions
and vote on questions.
So that will automatically refresh throughout
the session, and I'll take questions from
there and I'll alternate with questions from
the audience.
And so there's two standing microphones, one's
over there and one's over there.
I would recommend actually moving close to
the edges so that you have easy access to
the microphones if you want to ask any questions.
So that's it.
We have an hour.
Let's start with some intros.
Each of us will tell you our name and what
we work on, and we will try to say something
about either a recently launched product or
feature that we're excited about or something
that's coming up.
So I'll start.
My name is Jeff Chang, and I'm a product manager
on the Chrome browser.
And I'm currently responsible for end user
features and I also help coordinate the releases
that we do every six weeks.
And the recently launched feature which I'm
the most excited about, which hopefully you've
heard about by now, is tab sync, the synchronizing
of tabs across the many devices where you
use Chrome.
We had previously already had the ability
to sync your bookmarks and settings and other
stuff like that, but tab sync in particular
allows you to see all the tabs that you have
open on all of your other devices and open
any of them at any time, which I think is
really useful, especially across mobile and
desktop.
And the tab even includes the navigations
history, so you're right back where you left.
But that's me.
And I'll pass it off to Alex now.
>>Alex Komoroske: Cool.
Hi.
So my name is Alex Komoroske.
I'm a product manager on Chrome as well.
I focus on the open Web platform, so all the
technologies that Web developers use to build
cool apps.
My favorite stuff -- and if you saw my talk
on Wednesday this won't surprise you -- is
Web components.
So Web components is a new technology, a new
standard that's being developed.
So relatively early stages, but it promises
to allow people to totally change the way
they architect their Web apps and be much
more productive.
So I truly believe this is one of the technologies
that four years from now we'll look back and
say how did we build stuff without this?
I'm really excited about the Web components
in particular.
>>Erik Kay: Hi, my name is Erik Kay.
I'm an engineer on the Chrome team.
Actually, I've been with the Chrome team now
for a really long time, almost since it started,
which is actually getting close to six years
ago, believe it or not.
We were secret for almost two years at the
beginning.
And so even though we've only been out for
about four years now, it's been a long road
at this point.
Anyway, I've done everything from the auto
update system to Chrome extensions, and our
app system, and I also now help lead the Native
Client effort and a few other things.
The things I'm most excited about -- I'm actually
really excited about Web components too, Alex,
also.
I think that's pretty awesome.
But selfishly the new stuff we're doing with
apps I think will really be a big deal for
people who want to use Web technologies to
do more advanced applications going forward.
So I'm really excited to see what people are
going to build with that.
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: Hi.
My name is Ian Ellison-Taylor.
I'm the director of product management for
the Web platform.
And I'm just realizing I probably should have
sat at that end since we already covered a
couple of my favorite features in Web components,
and apps.
I think just to echo Erik's comment, I think
that what is coming with the new generation
of apps is going to be a game changer.
We kind of teased it just a little bit in
the keynote.
We tried not to really oversell it because
it's very early days, but there's a ton of
very cool stuff coming there.
But just is to make Pavel's life worse and
not repeat, probably the other thing -- the
other major area I'm really excited about
that's coming up in the next sort of 12 months
is around all the tools work.
We've got -- I think Pavel showed some amazing
stuff with our own dev tools in Chrome, but
if you also saw Adobe did a fantastic talk
on some of the work that they're doing around
Brackets and Shadow.
So -- and they're doing -- have done some
great work with Edge and designer focus tools
for the Web platform.
And then there are other lots of companies
as well, Cloud 9 to name but one.
So I think with a big investment in tooling
as well as on top of the platform we can make
it much easier for people like you to build
some amazing experiences.
So I think that's really going to help.
So I think that's pretty exciting.
>>Pavel Feldman: Thank you.
I'm Pavel Feldman, software engineer working
on the developer tools.
And the areas we are currently focusing on
are better authoring so that you can develop
Chrome within the tools, its memory.
As the platform matures we see a lot more
requests on the memory.
As your apps are running for days and weeks,
you better make sure you have no memory leaks.
So we have a new heap profiler, we have new
tools for native memory measurement, lots
of stuff there.
The other area that is important for us is
support for mobile.
We are working on the remote debugging for
the mobile and as well as emulating mobile
handsets on your desktop.
We do support the -- we've created the remote
debugging protocol that we are happy to see
other big players using now around WebKit.
The other area that is important for us is
the rendering smoothness, and you've seen
a couple of sessions on that yesterday.
That's where we make sure your apps are buttery
smooth.
And we are happy to see more and more requests
there.
And overall we are happy to see the way the
platform matures and the way you have more
and more demand in the tooling.
>>Felix Lin: I'm Felix Lin and I'm on the
product team for Chrome OS.
I spend most of my time working with hardware
partners to bring Chrome devices to markets.
I guess I'm most excited about the recent
Samsung Chromebook and Chromebox that were
just released, and the close working relationship
over the past couple of years we've developed
with Intel and Samsung and Qualcomm and all
the other folks in the PC ecosystem building
devices.
I'm a huge fan of Chrome, as you can imagine.
I love all the things these guys have built,
but what we're really trying to do with Chrome
OS is fully integrate Chrome directly with
the hardware and deliver the best possible
experience in a fully integrated package.
And so the benefit of Chromebooks and Chromeboxes
and other devices is that, you know, when
we can control the entire stack all the way
down to the hardware, we can deliver the best
possible experience for Chrome and the Web
on any hardware that people have.
And so it's not about replacing PC's or replacing
other devices, but for the people who are
spending more and more time on the Web, what
we want to do is just deliver an awesome,
magical experience for all the rich, immersive
experiences that you guys are building for
the Web.
>>Jeff Chang: Great.
All right.
So now we're open for questions.
Feel free to walk up to any of the microphones
and ask or otherwise we will trade off with
the --
>>Erik Kay: We'll take precedent for the people
who actually take some bravery and walk to
the mic.
[Laughter].
>>Erik Kay: We'll just intersperse the ones
from moderator here.
>>Jeff Chang: All right.
>>> Hi.
Good morning.
I've got a question.
We're seeing yesterday that it's possible
to open tabs on other devices, and sometimes
if you're like left at home or you have the
devices -- the tabs open there and you open
on a mobile device, will it be possible to
close the tabs that are home because I read
it on the mobile device, it's done, the task
is done?
>>Erik Kay: Yeah, I want that, too.
>>Jeff Chang: So the question was it's great
that you can open tabs that are on other devices
from your other devices, but what about closing
them as well?
That's a really interesting feature request.
We'll have to think about that.
It might be possible if Chrome is running
on that device, but if that device has already
been shut down, obviously you couldn't do
it immediately.
>>Erik Kay: I think we could do it.
>>Jeff Chang: Maybe we could -- maybe we could
figure something out there.
But yeah, I imagine that could be useful.
But yeah, when we started designing that feature
we talked about tab sync, I think we realized
pretty quickly on that you wouldn't want the
exact same set of tabs duplicated everywhere.
So that's not the way it works.
It's more or less a dashboard almost.
You can see all of the devices you have, what's
open on each one and you just pick and choose
what you want.
But we'll definitely keep that in mind.
>>> Great, thank you.
>>> +1!
>>> Can I make a question on Chrome OS?
>>Jeff Chang: Yes.
>>> What's the road map on Chrome OS and VPN?
Sometimes to configure Chrome OS to VPN's
and getting to the site of a network it's
been a little bit of a hassle.
>>Felix Lin: So Chrome OS today already supports
VPN's and we're doing a ton of work through
the management console to enable I.T. administrators
to centrally manage an entire fleet of devices
quickly and easily to support different authentication
schemes, different access control mechanisms
and all that.
>>Jeff Chang: Looks like we have another megaphone
question over here.
>>> Hi.
I'm wondering if anything is in the works
to improve drag and drop interoperability
between Web apps.
So A couple of years ago we had the ability
to do file drag and drop in HTML5 and it was
fantastic and I would love to see sort of
the next evolution so I could, for instance,
be in Gmail and just drag an attachment out
of a message over to another application that
can do something with that file and have that
application be able to sort of interact with
Gmail to pull in the information it needs
and do something, or vice versa, drag out
of an application on to a Gmail, et cetera.
>>Alex Komoroske: So that's a great use case
there.
And there isn't exactly precisely a standard
respect being developed to do precisely what
you're asking for, but something that does
something sort of similar is Web Intents,
which is a spec that we're driving that allows
applications to say I have an attach or whatever
and allow the users to pick which application
they would like to sort of service that request
with.
So theoretically you could have a loose coupling
between Gmail and any other Web app that would
want to view those images or what you have.
But that's a good point that users are familiar
with drag and drop and it makes sense to be
able to drag and drop these things between
tabs, but that's not something that's currently
on the roadmap.
>>Erik Kay: Yeah.
I just want to emphasize that last point,
is loose coupling.
So Web Intents is another one of these really
exciting Web technologies that I think is
going to change the Web in a year.
That you're going to look and say, oh, my
God, how did we interact without this?
Because the idea is that now Gmail can interact
with a whole host of Web apps that it knows
nothing about.
It didn't have to be performed with the knowledge
that Oh, I want to save this attachment to
Dropbox or G Drive or whatever else or that
I want to share this picture with Twitter
or Google+ or whatever else.
That it's up to you in the apps that are provided.
And just that fact that we can now have these
websites interoperate without having to hard
code relationships between them I think is
going to be a game changer.
>>Jeff Chang: Cool.
Any other megaphone questions?
All right.
Let's take one from the Google moderator page.
So offline it's pretty important for the Chrome
OS story.
What features are missing from the Web platform
that would help drive offline application
uses?
>>Alex Komoroske: I'll take a stab at this
one.
There already are a suite of technologies
in the Web platform that allow you to do offline
things.
You've got things like Local Storage, you
have app cache, Index DB and others.
They aren't necessarily a joy to use right
now, but they do exist as alternatives to
build upon.
The file API is a great -- another great example.
But I would argue actually that the way to
think about really driving offline application
usage is the way you develop your applications.
So if you develop your application with an
always on server -- always connected through
a server mindset, you're going to approach
it in certain ways and architect your app
in certain ways.
And then when you try to layer on offline
it can be pretty challenging because you don't
have that server connection all the time.
So actually orienting yourself as a developer
and saying I'm going to start at the beginning
working in this world where I don't know if
I have internet connection, it sort of forces
you actually to pivot your thinking and to
design your apps in a different way.
And that's a great thing about the new -- the
next evolution of Chrome apps is actually
they encourage you as a developer to start
from this world where you are sort of offline
by default, and connecting to the server is
almost an exception.
So that really orients you to sort of the
architecture app in the way that really works
for offline.
>>Erik Kay: Right.
So thanks for the shout-out to the Chrome
apps, but the -- we really want to emphasize
that this is one of these key architectural
things that we are building in from the beginning
for Chrome apps is to say that apps should
be written to be offline by default and we're
doing a lot of things built in to them to
make it possible to make it easy for you to
not get -- you know, get your app into a bad
state.
One of the interesting things about offline
is people sort of get hung up on, you know,
Oh, well, I've got connectivity everywhere.
Why do we need offline?
And it's because offline isn't such a straightforward
thing.
It's not a question of am I on an airplane
with no connectivity?
It's, Oh, well, sometimes I've got spotty
connectivity on my cell network or other times
I'm at a trade show with 5,000 people all
using the same Wi-Fi, you know, connection
or other times I'm at a hotel with a captive
proxy or, you know -- there's -- offline is
-- has a wide spectrum actually, and making
your apps that is resistant, resilient to
these network conditions takes a little bit
of forethought.
You have to build app, assume that it's offline
and basically you're operating on local data
and syncing with the server.
And all these features that Alex was talking
about with local storage, operating on that
local data, having your code running locally
to begin with and then synchronizing the server
and as you get network connectivity is sort
of the key to making offline work.
>>Jeff Chang: All right.
The computer that was projecting the URL for
the questions just died and won't start up.
So we're going to try to replace that, but
hopefully we have a pretty good queue of Google
moderator questions there and audience questions,
so let's keep going.
>>> Morning.
So Chrome is a leader of the HTML5 standard,
no doubt.
I was curious on the roadmap for the mobile
Android version of Chrome, when that would
kind of catch up to the current platform.
Specifically in my case for the WebGL implementation,
being that that's super hard in Tegra and
Intel chipsets, but I just wondered if it
was on the roadmap and where that might fall.
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: Is anyone from that
team here?
[ Laughter ]
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: Oh, is there someone
in the back?
Oh, yes.
Oh, Mrs. Smith, good Lord!
Yes, Grace, come down and maybe answer this
question, otherwise I'll make up something
like it will be there next week, maybe Tuesday.
>>> Yeah.
[Indiscernible] is also here.
So WebGL we are under development behind the
flags.
There's a performance issue that you just
mentioned and then there's a potential DOS
attack.
So we try to work with like OEM device drivers
to try to address these problems.
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: The high level strategy,
of course, is that all these features end
up on mobile.
There's implementation issues, and also recognizing
that the unique power management requirements
make it a little bit tricky, but generally
when we do new features in the Web platform
we're thinking about the mobile scenarios.
Almost -- I would say first and foremost generally.
We worry a little bit less about the desktop
because that's an easier scenario.
So pretty much everything.
I can't think of anything off the top of my
head that we're not thinking about being in
mobile sooner or later.
So hopefully we'll -- that lag between desktop
and mobile will get shorter and shorter.
>>Alex Komoroske: So there's also -- there's
a little bit of this temporary lag, but the
fact that Chrome for Android is relatively
new.
So we're still going through and making sure
we get all those pieces that we worked on
to make Chrome for Android work back into
Chrome.
So that process takes a little bit of time,
which is why it takes a little bit for us
to catch up to where desktop Chrome is right
now, but that's a temporary problem.
So there's a long-term problem of some of
these features that you have to make sure
you design it in the mobile -- to work well
in mobile use case and other ones that it
just takes awhile for us to catch up to the
desktop.
>>Jeff Chang: Okay.
Next question from the moderator page is,
OSX 10.8 has a power nap feature that keeps
various bits of a user's data synced while
the machine is suspended, email, et cetera.
Any plans for such a feature in Chrome OS?
Felix, do you want to try to take this one?
I guess, you can look at it on that screen,
too.
Since that machine is broken anyway, maybe
we can get that screen mirrored on that screen.
>>Felix Lin: So this is definitely a feature
that we're looking at.
I don't know exactly when we'll have this
feature in Chrome OS.
Certainly as we work with Intel and other
hardware partners, these types of capabilities
are much easier for us to implement because
we have full knowledge of the hardware that's
running in these systems and we can actually
design them.
The great thing about Chrome OS, though, is
that you could buy a machine today and if
that machine has the capability at all to
make this possible, we'll roll out that feature
and you will get it automatically.
So a lot of these features, when we spec the
minimum requirements for Chrome OS boxes,
a lot of what we're doing is looking forward
and making sure that we've got the kind of
head room that we need to be able to add new
features, new capabilities, even though what
we release on any given day may not include
this full set of capabilities.
>>Alex Komoroske: I should point out as well,
this basic feature, this basic request, makes
sense in a lot of different scenarios.
It makes sense, especially on mobile as well,
where you don't know, you don't want to constantly
have your radio powered up.
There's also been, with these event pages.
Generally we're moving towards a model where
it's possible for Web apps to sort of allow
Chrome to wake them up, do a little bit of
work, put them back to sleep in response to
events.
That's really basically the core of what power
nap is doing as well.
So we are looking into this on multiple fronts.
So while Jeff is figuring that out, I'll move
on to the next one.
Okay.
Will I ever be able to run Chrome OS on a
tablet, maybe even a Nexus 7 tablet?
>>Felix Lin: That's a great question.
[ Laughter ]
>>Felix Lin: Um, Chrome OS was really designed
to run on a variety of form factors, so there's
nothing about Chrome OS that says that we
can't run on a tablet or pick your device
form factor.
The first device that we focused on, because
of the complexity of use case, is the calm
shell where we just bring full capabilities
of Chrome to bear.
You know, today, Google's OS for tablets is
Android and we are able to bring all of the
capabilities of Chrome to Android for Jelly
Bean and Ice Cream Sandwich.
We're working on creating a completely seamless,
coherent experience across all devices, regardless
of whether the underlying OS happens to be
Android or Chrome OS.
So from the user standpoint, whether you are
buying content from the play store or whether
you are running an app, our goal is to make
it such that you don't have to worry about
whether it's actually Android or Chrome OS
running on that tablet; we want that to work.
>>Jeff Chang: Next.
How will the two operating systems, Android
and Chrome OS, eventually converge?
Yeah, we get asked -- we've been asked about
this in the past, you know, one thing to keep
in mind is that Chrome OS has the goal of
designing an end-to-end computing experience
that -- that embodies kind of the same core
principles as Chrome does, the security, and,
you know, over time we've been thinking about
what parts of the technologies between those
two makes sense to integrate, right?
We are very happy to say that Chrome for Android
came out of beta this week, so Chrome for
Android is now stable.
And maybe Felix you have some other comments
on this or --
>>Erik Kay: Well, I can add a few things.
I mean, one thing is that you'll see, I think
you are going to see more and more convergence
over time.
You know, we -- first off just bringing Chrome,
you know, to Android was sort of the first
big step.
But there are many places where we -- where
we can integrate more.
First off, getting the same set of apps running,
using the same cloud infrastructure.
But I think the opportunities doing some of
the -- I think the Chrome-to-phone stuff that
we had before, we're looking to -- to have
-- to leverage a lot of the same infrastructure
and to have more and more integration over
time.
>>Jeff Chang: All right.
Any other microphone questions?
Don't be shy.
Any plans for a messaging platform inside
of Chrome or Chrome OS, similar to C2DM or
iOS notifications, which I believe are coming
to the desktop?
>>Erik Kay: So we actually do have some -- effectively
with the sync we have a notification system
built into Chrome and into Chrome OS and it
turns out that behind the scenes a lot of
the, you know, infrastructure is very similar
and, again, as I said, that we're looking
to unify some of the basic infrastructure
that we share across Android and Chrome.
I would expect to see our messaging systems
converge as well.
>>Alex Komoroske: You can imagine the solution
wouldn't just have to be about messaging,
per se.
It could be about notifications, so different
apps could decide different things that were
worthwhile to do.
In fact, actually in the meet the Web platform
video series we showed off a mock of what
that could look like.
>>Jeff Chang: Cool.
All right, audience question.
>>> A question about Chrome apps.
What's the plan to get Chrome apps for Chrome
on Android, and how is it going to work?
Is it going to the Chrome Web store, it's
going to a (indiscernible) to play?
>>Erik Kay: Okay.
Let's see, how do we start with this?
First off, you know, it's a common question
that we get about what's our plan for getting,
you know, Chrome apps to mobile.
So you heard Sundar say at the keynote, I
said the other day at the apps talk we are
intending to get Chrome apps to mobile, basically
everywhere that we have Chrome.
Now how are we going to do that?
The details of that?
The timing of that?
You know, it's too early to say.
I can say that we're looking for your feedback.
We want to know from you what you want.
What are the most important features that
you want to see brought to mobile?
And just one last little plug, we are hiring.
[ Laughter ]
>>Erik Kay: So if you want to help make this
happen, you know --
>>> Cool.
>>Erik Kay: Exactly.
>>Jeff Chang: Cool, another audience question.
>>> Also about Chrome apps, you launched them
from within Chrome but with a new version
that will act a lot like they are native to
the platform.
Any thoughts about setting them up so you
would be able to launch them as if they were
a native app?
>>Erik Kay: Absolutely.
That's one of the key features of the next
evolution of Chrome apps here is that we are
pulling them outside of the browser.
It's not just that they have standalone Windows;
it's that the way that you launch them will
be without even necessarily having to have
Chrome running.
So basically you will just launch them from
the native desktop.
>>> When will we have private key SSH?
>>Erik Kay: Right.
So I know that the engineers working on that
pretty -- on the SSH thing for Chrome OS is
a top feature request.
So I know that it's going to come.
I don't know what the timeline is.
>>Jeff Chang: All right.
Looks like we've got someone walking up to
the microphone.
Go ahead.
>>> Why was the change to Aura made?
I know when the Chrome was initially announced,
the launch video mentioned that you didn't
even have a desktop background.
And the change on -- to Aura in the newer
version of Chrome OS did make it a lot more
like a desktop operating system.
What was the decision, why did that happen?
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: It was 99% user feedback.
I mean -- I think when we launched Chrome
OS in the particular UI model, it was something
of an experiment.
It was something that no one had ever done
before.
We said that we were going to update it based
on user feedback.
And obviously I think Sundar made the point
about performance improvements and feature
improvements, but people just gave us their
feedback that they wanted it to be a little
bit more like a -- you know, a "traditional"
OS and particularly I think that model, I
mean this is just for me personally -- I will
let Felix talk a little bit.
For me personally the tab model I think worked
really well on the smaller screen.
But once you get to sort of Chromebox style
and you're on a large monitor, that's -- that
single large window gets a little weird, you
know.
It's like you get a huge crick in your neck
going from one side of the screen to the other.
So being able to like open multiple windows,
switch between -- then multi-tasking, now
I've got three or four things going on at
once, I want a quick way to switch between
them.
There's just a use case that seemed pretty
important.
And that you can very easily configure it
so it behaves like it used to if you don't
like that.
Then you just run everything full screen,
keep everything in a tab.
So if you're in that model, you don't really
lose anything, but if you want something a
little bit more traditional with multiple
windows, you can do that, too.
>>Felix Lin: I think the biggest benefit of
having a windowing system is that people can
do more than one thing at one time, right?
So a very, very common use case is writing
an email and checking your calendar, if you
have to flip between tabs and you only have
one pane, it's a pretty miserable experience.
Also, as -- as Ian was mentioning, you know
with the Chromebox we are now able to deliver
an experience on dual 30-inch monitors, if
you have got a huge desktop having one full-screen
window is not a great use of space.
>>Erik Kay: Also, one other kind of funny
thing that we discovered by having a full
screen browser, which is there's sort of an
interesting psychological effect for users.
So users have sort of preconceived notions
of what a browser can and can't do, it turns
out.
And so they see tabs, they see an address
bar, they see a back button and they immediately
assume, oh, well it's, you know, it's only
a Web page, it can't do everything an app
can do.
Or it certainly can't run offline, so there's
sort of these interesting things that sort
of get in the way just by having it there.
And as we move to more focus on apps within
Chrome OS and wanting to bring apps fronts
and center, it was important to pull those
out of the browser and really give them their
own windows.
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: That actually reminds
me since I tease this on Twitter about there
being an Easter egg.
It reminds me of one of them.
So Kan, if you saw the keynote yesterday,
Kan did the sort of the spinning window thing,
so that's in Chrome OS.
So that wasn't just something we rigged up
for the keynote.
You can -- it shows the power of the window
manager, so one of the keys is very obvious.
>>> Control alt and then refresh button or
something like that?
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: Sorry, what was that?
>>> Isn't it like control alt and then the
refresh button?
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: It may or may not be
that.
[ Laughter ]
>>> I have done it before.
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor:.
[ Laughter ]
You give it away.
But there's another -- another Easter egg
that was in the keynote as well.
I don't know if anyone spotted that one, but
I'll maybe talk about that later, if the questions
are good enough.
[ Laughter ]
>>Jeff Chang: Go ahead.
>>> Yeah, so the current Chromebook runs on
Intel or Celeron, but all of your Android
devices currently run on ARM, video, Qualcomm,
TI, respectively, if you're ever going to
get to a point in the future where you are
going to be able to dual boot a device, whether
it be a tablet or a laptop, desktop, or even
a smart phone down the road, into either Chrome
OS or Android, you have to get on the same
CPU hardware platform, is there anything inherent
that makes it difficult for Chrome OS to run
on say an ARM chip or is this just a matter
of timing that this is basically something
that you should expect at some undescript
point down the road?
>>Felix Lin: I think -- we can't talk about
any future products obviously.
But there's nothing about Chrome OS that limits
it to a particular processor architecture.
Completely open source.
In fact, many of the ARM vendors have brought
Chrome OS up on different ARM SOCs, and it's
really a matter of, you know, timing and price
point and, you know, a variety of other things
with respect to, you know, packaging a product
and bringing it to commercial release.
So I don't -- you know, basically there's
nothing holding anybody back.
Other than, you know, commitment to ship the
product.
>>Erik Kay: There is one thing that I will
toss out.
Which is it's not a limitation of Chrome OS.
It's more just sort of what our chip sets
have been building -- what the ARM chip sets
and manufacturers have been building, so their
main focus is on phones and now tablets, and
what's interesting is that phones and tablets
have smaller screens.
And it turns out that -- that the thing that
you need that's one of the biggest performance
bottlenecks on computers in general is memory
bandwidth between the CPU and the display
architecture.
And the bigger the screen, the more memory
bandwidth that you need.
Turns outs the smaller the screen, the less
you need, right, you know, conversely.
So it's an optimization that you can do to
make it use less power, to be cheaper and
that sort of a thing.
So many of the ARM chip sets are designed
to really be only efficient up to a certain
screen size.
So it turns out, this is one of the things
that held ARM back getting to the desktop,
bigger monitors, you know, hi-res.
But now as tablets have had -- now get an
increased density, increased size, increased
number of pixels, they've had to solve those
same memory bandwidth problems.
So I think we are right in the cusp of being
able to see really awesome desktop and laptop
ARM form factors coming and you will see it
probably for a variety of systems.
>>Jeff Chang: Thank you, next question.
The moderator page.
Speaking of sync, any plan for app syncing
as well, with an API that would allow apps
to sync their data as well?
>>Erik Kay: So, yes.
That already exists.
There's an extension API people can start
playing with today, storage API, Chrome.storage.sync,
basically it's a simple key value store so
you can sort of maintain your state and your
preferences and that sort of a thing.
It's an easy way to sort of move app and extension
settings from -- from machine to machine.
We have much more planned for doing more cloud-based
storage and making APIs available to apps.
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: And obviously there's
a quick plug for our colleagues on drive that
for applications to be able to store their
application, the user data, that's obviously
one of the goals for drive and getting drive
onto lots of devices.
So you get sort of both -- both parts of the
equation, your settings and your data that
can travel with you.
So sync is a huge part of the overall strategy
about what we think is really interesting
about having lots of devices, but a Chrome
experience on one of them.
So I think it's pretty key.
>>Jeff Chang: Okay.
So regarding Chrome OS and the enterprise,
what plans do you have for enhancing the management
and performance of Cloud Print, particularly
around management of over 1,000 printers at
a given company?
I know that in Chrome, we don't usually talk
about version numbers, but Chrome 20 stable
-- just went to the stable channel this past
week.
Actually, I take that back.
I'm mixing up my versions.
We are always managing multiple releases at
the same time, so we have four different channels,
I'm actually thinking about 21, 21 I know
has Cloud Printing more directly integrated
into the Chrome's print dialogue itself, so
it's easier to find your printers more easily
when you are printing.
And know that that dialogue has a search box
that you can search across all of the printers
that are available to you.
So I hope that's -- that the UI team has considered
the issue of -- of when you have lots of printers
there, although I think this question might
be around more from the enterprise.
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: Yeah.
Actually, I wonder if any here -- if they
have any from Cloud Print here.
They have a session today, so if there's no
one from the cloud print team right here,
definitely go to that session and ask them
if they have done a lot of work there.
So they can probably answer the question.
>>Jeff Chang: Cloud Print is actually the
last session in this room today, I think.
>>Erik Kay: Actually, just so you know, I
mean one of the big strengths that we've seen
with -- with Chromebooks and Chrome OS has
been enterprise management.
This ability to, you know, drop in, you know,
a thousand new devices and just hand them
out.
And you not have to image them and configure
them on a per user basis and deploy a whole
bunch of stuff to them is one of the key strengths
we see of Chrome OS.
And so we've been investing pretty heavily
in the enterprise management console to really
make that better.
So if there's any limitations on that, we
want to hear about it.
File bugs, you know, talk to us.
Because we think that this is an area that
we can really own.
>>Jeff Chang: Yeah, we have an audience question.
>>> So I came in a little bit late, I don't
know if you addressed this yet, but I was
curious about what's the state of eating your
own dogfood within Google?
If you could talk about the transition of
getting people to be full-time Chromebook
users instead of regular desktop users.
Are people doing that?
How successful is it?
What kind of experience have you had?
>>Jeff Chang: Sure, yeah.
The question is asking, you know, about the
phrase eating our own dogfood, which means
using our own products as they are being developed
at Google.
I can say for sure for Chrome browser, I definitely
eat my own dogfood.
I run Canary, which is the nightly auto update,
built side-by-side with the beta installation
on my machine.
So I actually use Canary every day, so I can
stay with the latest engineering.
But I don't recommend that to normal folks.
It's painful at times.
And in terms of Chromebooks, I certainly carry
around my Chromebook with me.
I have it right over there and I use it and
it's really convenient when I'm going to meetings
and stuff, especially when I want to get out
an email in like 60 seconds or something.
Open it up on my lid, press the button and
be able to fire off the email and close my
lid within 30 seconds while, you know, like
my other Windows laptop might be churning
away on the anti-virus thing for like a minute
because Google corporate makes us run anti-virus
on them.
So, yeah, we definitely see that a lot around
the office.
But I do, you know, use multiple devices and
multiple operating systems.
And for Canary on Windows, I run that, because
I want to get the latest code from our engineers
as soon as possible.
>>> Do you have anyone going cold turkey,
just Chrome OS exclusively?
>>Felix Lin: I can tell you that the dogfooders
at Google who are using Chrome OS have skyrocketed
since we released the latest Chromebooks running
on Intel Corp.
You know the great thing about Google -- two
things, right?
We have access to whatever computer we want.
If you want a Macbook Air or Macbook Pro,
whatever high-end system you want, you can
have it.
If you want a Chromebook, you can have it.
We don't force anybody to dogfood Chrome OS,
so everybody who is using Chrome OS uses it
by choice, and when you think about it, the
fact that you see people, more and more Googlers
who have their pick of any hardware that they
want walking around with Chromebooks, typically
which cost often a fraction of what they could
be spending, it's pretty remarkable.
I can tell you that with the latest Chromeboxes
and the latest Chromebooks, these devices
are just completely hassle free, battery life,
power management, superb, you know, even the
-- the first generation Chromebook, just because
of the fact that we have so many existing
customers on older hardware and the fact that
we're constantly updating even older hardware
with newer releases of Chrome OS, you know,
I switch devices continuously, and so yesterday
during a keynote when you saw Brian talk about
the fact that, you know, he's got 7 or 8 different
machines and he just walks from one machine
to the next, he doesn't carry a single machine
he has to worry about, you know, that is all
possible because of Chrome and Chrome OS.
You know, when you're using a machine which
is a year old and you pick it up one day,
and it's running 30% faster than the day before,
because you've got the auto update pushed
to you, it's really noticeable, and users
really love it, and so even today, even though
I've got, you know, you know, the latest Samsung
Chromebook, when I switch to the device that
I've been using for over a year, I really
don't notice much of a performance difference
for most of the things that I do.
I'll notice some things for, you know, high-end
video and things like that, but the device
is completely usable, it's just great.
>>Erik Kay: So let me give you another perspective.
I do use my Chromebook exclusively as my laptop,
I have to use a different laptop, because
in engineering we to test on a bunch of different
platforms, but I do live on my Chromebook,
and it's pretty common now within Google especially
with the hardware, I'll say that the IT staff
within Google, you know, loves it and they
want more people to switch over, as soon as
they can, and Google -- Googlers are a really
demanding audience.
It turns out that, as Felix said, they can
use whatever hardware they want, and -- and
a lot of them are doing heavy-duty development
tasks and that sort of thing, and so making
hardware that is going to be good enough for
the majority of Googlers to actually get their
job done is a tall task, and the biggest bit
of feedback that we heard early on was that
for Googlers the previous generation of hardware
wasn't quite powerful enough.
And now the feedback that we've gotten from
people, is like, wow, this is actually -- this
has crossed the line and it's great, it's
easy, and totally what they want.
Now, they want more of course and so we're
working to make -- build even more powerful
machines and a wider variety of form factors,
and trust us when we say that Googlers are
some of the most demanding audience out there,
and -- but the rate that they're growing and
they're selecting in and using it themselves
is going through the roof.
>>> It is a great idea to have kind of your
computer as like an appliance or kiosk, and
I feel very nervous if I have anything on
a single machine, that is my only copy, I
like moving everything to the cloud, just
being able to -- but I know that there's lots
of little, you know, dusty corners of our
lives where they're not all, you know, able
to be pushed to the cloud on Chrome OS yet,
so it's nice that you guys are kind of filling
in those holes.
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: That's a great point.
I'm the same way.
Since I don't do development, I'm 99% -- 99.9%
of my time is spent on a Chromebook, and mostly
that -- honestly it's about I'm old and I
need a keyboard, I love tablets, but I spend
all my time in e-mail, I just need to be able
to type on a real keyboard, but I love the
battery life, that sort of 8, 9 hours, I can
get through the day and I don't have to carry
the little power brick around, so the battery
life thing is huge for me when I'm running
around campus.
Another thing that's really nice about Google,
and I bounce between different offices, I'll
often not carry a machine with me, and I'll
go to the other office, we have these little
tech stop places and I can grab a Chromebook
from tech stop, I just log in, carry on from
where I left off, and then I just hand it
back at the end of the day, and I just don't
have to travel with anything, so when I'm
going through security, and, you know, just
everything gets so much easier when I can
just pick up that machine, log in, carry on,
hand it back and not worry, like what did
I leave on that machine?
What was I doing?
Did I do anything weird today?
So for me, that's a hugely important use case,
and I think we'll see more of that as time
goes on.
>>> Thanks.
>>Jeff Chang: Let's take a question from this
side.
>>> My question is on moderator but it seems
to have dropped off.
I just want to know about international availability
of Chrome OS devices particularly the new
Samsung Chromebook, because I'm from New Zealand
and, yeah, we just don't have access to them
there.
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: What's the international
access for Chromebooks, particularly the new
one.
Particularly New Zealand?
>>Felix Lin: So the new Chromebooks are currently
available in US and UK.
We're looking at getting them certified in
more countries as quickly as possible, but,
you know, as with all things, it's a matter
of just figuring out where the demand is and
how to role out in more countries and get
the certifications.
You know, the demand for the new Chromebooks,
i think, have greatly exceeded the expectations
and so, again, it's just a matter of time,
but we're working on getting it out there.
>>> Okay, thanks.
>>Jeff Chang: All right.
Back to this -- actually, I'll go ahead and
let's do a couple of these.
At least one of these.
How far is Web GL support for mobile versions
of Chrome?
I think we already answered that earlier up
at the microphone.
Next question here is about Chrome on iOS.
So for you guys in here, we launched Chrome
on iOS yesterday, we actually it's like the
number one ranked in the app store now, right?
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: Yeah, Chrome on iOS
was number one, and drive on iOS was number
two.
We'll see how long that lasts.
>>Jeff Chang: So we're happy that --
[ Applause ]
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: Thank you.
>>Jeff Chang: We are definitely very happy
that we were able to get that out to you guys,
especially with the think store we've been
telling, it's very important that we have
Chrome available on as many platforms as possible.
In terms of how Chrome runs on iOS, you know,
we obviously have to follow Apple's technical
specifications there, so in terms of the actual
Web content it does use the UR WebView.
I don't know if anyone else has any comments
there.
>>Erik Kay: So there's two things: You have
to think about performance on a number of
different axis, right?
So one is how long does it take -- how fast
is it to just get around and get your work
done and do stuff like that and then the second
thing is there's raw compute performance or
rendering performance within the page.
I guess you could count those as three areas.
So on the compute -- on the pure compute side
of things, like if you were to download just
a JavaScript benchmark, we're limited by what
Apple provides us in that they don't allow
you to run your own jitted, you know, JavaScript
engine.
They don't allow you to provide your own rendering
-- you know, Web rendering engine, it's just
not allowed by the terms of service, and so
we have to use UI WebView, and the UI WebView
is actually more restrictive than what's in
Safari.
Even though it's some of the own code, they
actually turn off some features.
And one of the things they turn off is the
use of the JIT in their JavaScript engine,
so that slows down heavy-duty JavaScript things.
The second thing it does is it affects some
of the GPU acceleration, how that interoperates.
So we have some limitations there, so if you
wanted to do just sort of the raw how fast
is this particular page spinning in a loop
doing stuff, we aren't going to be as fast
as we are on other platforms just due to limitations;
however, the good news is is that that's not
the entire story.
The usability, you know, in terms of how long
does it take you to get from point A to point
B is how much we predict what you're going
to type, that helps with sync, your usage
patterns, the Omni box, how we're able to
pre-fetch -- guess what you're able to do
using our pre-rendering and some of our DNS
pre-fetching stuff.
We have a lot of tricks within Chrome beyond
just the JavaScript engine and what we're
doing inside the Web rendering engine.
So actually if you read some of the reviews
that are floating around out there, if you
see the ones that load up a benchmark and
compare them AB, you'll see that we're slower.
If you see the ones that try to use it and
say I navigated to the following three sites
and time that, you'll see that we're actually
way faster, that some people are getting things
done twice as fast.
Getting to their web pages, so if what you're
doing is surfing and navigating around, actually
I think you'll find Chrome on iOS is really
fast.
>>Jeff Chang: Yeah, for me just the fact that
all my favorite websites all ready auto complete.
It just helps a ton, and for me I use a lot
of tabs.
I tend to open a lot of tabs in the background
when I'm reading stuff, like read it or something.
Being able to flip through really easy, switch
through them is a huge usability improvement
for me.
All right.
Go ahead.
>>> On a similar note, one of the things that
makes Chrome so much more fast than anything
else is the extensions, and in particular
for me, the Omni box extension capability
of making completion work.
When are you considering bringing this to
mobile?
>>Erik Kay: So I think we talked a little
bit about this before, but basically, you
know, Chrome is a pretty big set of features
and the Web has a very broad set of features
and so we only just got, you know, Android
to -- Chrome to Android a few months ago,
and we only just got Chrome to iOS today,
or yesterday.
So we've got a little ways to go to get to
feature parity, and extension is one of those
parts that we actually like to take our time
with because it has, you know, deep integration
to all of the various hooks in the browser.
We also think that in mobile it's quite likely
that how you want to extend the browser is
going to be different.
Also the performance needs of mobile are different.
So -- so some of the changes we've been making
in the desktop has have been anticipating
our needs in mobile.
If you look at the new stuff we've done with
event pages in extensions where basically
there's no longer going to be an always-running
persistent background page for every single
extension, that way we can be a little more
on demand, this is partly to reduce the resource
function of extensions, and we think will
make it more adaptable to mobile down the
road.
Unfortunately, you know, I don't have a good
timetable to tell you, but it is something
we're interested in.
>>Jeff Chang: All right, switch over to this
side again.
>>> I'm curious if there's going to be any
advancements in printer support without Google
Cloud Print.
Right now it seems like you need a separate
machine in order to be able to print.
Is there any way that it's going to be possible
with a Chromebook alone.
>>Jeff Chang: Sounds like you're asking about
printing outside of Google cloud but specifically
for Chrome OS.
>>> Yes.
>>Felix Lin: Today people can use any of their
legacy printers by using Cloud Print through
an existing machine on the network.
On my home machine I have windows XP set up,
I've got Cloud Print installed and I can get
to any of my legacy printers on the network
through that with pretty much every printer
I'm aware of on the market today.
They're already Cloud Print enabled, so by
simply going any new printer that you get
today pretty much can just be on the network
and accessible to any Chrome OS or any other
device that uses Cloud Print.
>>> Oh, okay.
>>Jeff Chang: All right.
Back to this side.
>>> I found out I think next year that Google
is giving my daughter's school a bunch of
Chrome OS netbooks and we live right next
to Mountain View, so I was just curious like
what's the thinking behind that, and is it
more than just a local thing?
Is it like going to be in other places around
the country?
>>Jeff Chang: So I know for sure that we've
had a lot of -- a lot of schools around the
country starting to adopt Chromebooks.
Felix can probably tell you the exact numbers,
but I know that the feedback has been very
positive.
>>Felix Lin: Education is one of the most
-- most aggressively verticals adopting Chromebooks.
And the beauty of the Web and education is
that, you know, the Web is really a great
equalizer, right?
All the best content, apps, information, accessible
to students, very, very low cost, always up-to-date.
Chromebooks are phenomenal platform for schools
because schools have, you know, shrinking
budgets, no IT staff, and being able to take
a device that has zero maintenance, zero management,
always up to date, doesn't require a ton of
care and feeding, and gives people access
to all of the tools that they use is really
just a great formula for education.
We're -- in addition to, you know, the hundreds
and hundreds of schools I think in 48 states,
there are schools that are deploying Chromebooks,
we're seeing huge initiatives at national
levels where in many emerging markets countries
are looking to Chromebooks as a way to, you
know, transform education and really transform
great economic transformation across the country.
And, you know, it's really all about, you
know, the rich content that's available, all
the educational material that is available,
and just the ability to get a situation where
instead of, you know, a 20 students to one
computer type ratio in a school, giving students
a one to one opportunity where every student
has a computer that they're using to enhance
their learning, is truly transformational.
And so, you know, from our standpoint, and,
you know, this is the great thing about working
with many of our hardware partners, in education
we're finding a great willingness on the part
of companies to be able to foster education.
People don't seem to have as large a profit
motive in education as they do in other verticals
where they need to be making, you know, an
enterprise profit, but this is just a huge
opportunity for us and for -- for future students.
>>Jeff Chang: All right, back to this side.
>>> Okay.
Congratulations, by the way, on shipping Chrome
for iOS.
It's a good thing.
I was in a session yesterday afternoon, optimizing
your HTML for -- for a mobile device, and
the presenter invited us to follow along,
give URL for slides, and said we're going
to working on this interactively, so I pulled
out my iPad and downloaded Chrome for the
iPad, and was following right along, and then
he said, okay, now we're going to install
the page speed extension, so we can watch
and see what happens, and I said, great, search
for page speed, right here, Chrome Web store,
and it said umm, the Chrome Web store is not
supported on your OS.
>>Erik Kay: I tried to touch on this earlier,
but extensions are something we definitely
want to support down the road on mobile and
other platforms.
It's just very early days and getting into
mobile is going to take us a fair amount of
work.
>>> Okay.
>>Jeff Chang: Go ahead.
>>> So another Chrome on iOS question.
I'm just wondering if it does or is going
to support URL schemes so that iOS developers
launch Chrome if they choose to.
>>Erik Kay: Do we have anybody from the iOS
team around here that can answer that?
Tell you what, why don't you -- if you want
we can look that up for you and leave your
e-mail for us.
>>Jeff Chang: We can put you in touch with
the right people.
>>> Okay, thanks.
>>> Hi.
>>Jeff Chang: Hi.
>>> I have a question about my Chromebook.
I would like to use it as a Web development
platform with my HTML JavaScript files, and
I tried that yesterday and then I ran into
two problems.
One is that I don't have a text editor for
my HTML files, and I saw one of the presentations
that was using an app, I want to know which
app that is.
And the second problem is how to run my HTML
files from Google Drive.
I only get a preview of the source code.
I don't get a run.
>>Erik Kay: So I can talk to that.
So that you're probably talking about our
presentation where we had some text editors
running on Chrome OS, and this is using some
of the new apps features that we've been working
on.
They're pretty early on, so they're right
now available to people developing in Canary,
but we hope to have them more broadly available
later this year.
If you're a developer, want to ride the ragged
edge, you know, you can come check out -- we've
got some sample code.
I think that particular little micro editor
is checked into GitHub, and our Google Chrome
repo, but a warning is that it's early, it's
very simple.
It actually isn't as cool as it looked.
We -- we -- we actually hit over all the rough
spots.
But there are -- I'll tell you that just one
of the cool, fun things about the new apps
stuff we've been doing, is just once you add
these new capabilities of seeing what people
want to build with them, and within Chrome
team, one of the first things people wanted
to build actually was code editors, and in
fact we have like three of them already that
people are just doing different things with,
and so we actually expect there to be a plethora
of code editors.
>>Jeff Chang: I don't know if you mentioned
it already or not, there's definitely IDEs
available in the Chrome Web store.
A bunch of them are pretty highly ranked.
>>Jeff Chang: The number of cloud ID's emerging
and you can use them, and as the Chrome, we
are providing them with the extension APIs
so they could plug into the instrumentation
and get the dev tools integrated into the
cloud tools, so you have both complete ID
with the remote persistence and the debugging
capabilities on the Chrome OS.
But it's all coming.
We're working on that.
We're working with base teams on these capabilities.
>>> And then how do I run my HTML file?
When I clicked on the file from Google Drive,
I just got a preview.
>>Erik Kay: So you have to ask the Drive team,
so unfortunately none of us are from there,
so I don't know if they have any plans to
allow direct hosting of HTML straight from
Drive.
I assume that's what you mean for public consumption,
but if you just want to do local development,
it should be possible to do -- to read the
files locally and render them, you know, in
Chrome.
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: (inaudible)
>>Erik Kay: Yeah, we can check with the drive
team.
>>Jeff Chang: Yeah, we can check with the
Drive team.
It looks like we pretty much ran out of time.
>>Ian Ellison-Taylor: Hang on.
I forgot one other Easter Egg, you probably
already know, there's another Easter Egg in
the video, the History of Chrome, so you might
want to study that video and -- and there's
something pretty cool in there so --
>>Jeff Chang: All right.
Perfect timing.
Yeah.
So thank you for coming.
We enjoy doing this every year as long as
you guys come, and so hopefully see you next
year, otherwise if you just stay in this room,
there's a bunch of Chrome sessions after us,
looks like high performance HTML5, history
and future of Google Web tool kit, writing
secure Web Apps, and Chrome extensions and
the Google Cloud Print section, so please
enjoy the rest of conference, and thank you.
[ Applause ]